This is going to begin a two lecture
sequence on social psychology,
on how we think about ourselves,
how we think about other people,
how we think about other groups of people.
We've talked a lot about the capacities
of the human mind and some of these
capacities involve adapting and
dealing with the material world.
So we have to choose foods,
we have to navigate around the world,
we have to recognize objects,
we have to be able to um,
to understand physical interactions.
But probably the most interesting aspect
of our evolved minds is our capacity to
understand and neo of other people,
we are intensely interested
in how other people work.
Um,
the story that was the dominant
news story in 2005 was this,
and some of you,
this,
for those of you who run seeing the screen
is the separation of Jennifer Aniston
and Brad Pitt. I remember where I
was when I first heard about this
and it's an interesting site.
Just remember stepping back, um,
as psychologists we have
to question the natural.
We have to take things that are
common sense and explore them.
And one thing which was just happens
is we're fascinated by this stuff.
We're fascinated by the
lives of celebrities,
were fascinated by the
social lives of other people.
And it's an interesting
question to ask why. Um,
and this is one of the questions which
I'm going to deal with in the next couple
of lectures, but before I get to
the theory of social psychology,
I want to talk about an
individual difference.
So we devoted a lecture early on about
a couple of weeks ago to individual
differences across people in
intelligence and personality.
I want to talk a little bit about India,
an individual difference
in our social natures.
And then I want people to do a test
that we'll explore where you stand on a
continuum. Um, that test is the piece
of paper you have in front of you.
Anybody who doesn't have it,
please raise your hand.
And when a teaching fellows
will bring it to you,
you don't know what to do yet
with it. Um, so don't worry.
The test was developed actually by
Malcolm Gladwell, who's a science writer,
um, in his wonderful
book, the tipping point.
And as he introduces the
test, Gladwell recounts, um,
another experiment done by
Stanley Milgram, of course,
famous for his obedience work,
but he did a lot of interesting things.
And one classic study he did was he gave a
to hundred and 60 people randomly
chosen in Omaha, Nebraska.
And he asked these people
to get the package somehow.
And this was many years
ago before the internet,
before email to get the package to a
stockbroker who worked in Boston but lived
in Sharon,
Massachusetts.
What he found was that most
people were able to do it.
Nobody of course knew this man,
but they knew people who might know
people who would know this man.
So most people succeeded.
Most people were able to get
the packages to this man and um,
and it took at maximum
six degrees of separation,
which is where the frame is famous race
comes about that we're all separated
from another person by six degrees of
separation. This is not true in general.
This was a very, a single experiment
done within the United States.
But the idea is appealing that people are
connected to one another via chains of
people.
MMM.
But what milligram found was
particularly interesting was that
in about half of the cases these
packages went through to people.
That is, if you plot the
relationships between people,
we can take each person in this room,
find everybody you know,
and who knows you and draw a line.
But if we were to do this,
you wouldn't find an even mesh of wires.
Rather you'd find that
some people are clusters,
some people are what Gladwell calls
connectors. It's like air traffic.
Air traffic used to be um,
everything flew to,
to two places local to it.
But now there's a system of hubs.
Chicago O'hare for instance,
our Newark,
we're planes fly through.
Some people are hubs.
Some people are the sort of
people who know a lot of people.
Some people in this room might be hubs
and it is not impossible to find out.
The piece of paper you have here is
250 names rent chosen randomly from a
Manhattan phone book.
Okay.
They capture a range of ethnicities,
different parts of the world.
Different, uh, different national origins.
Here's what I'd like you to do and I'll
give you about five minutes for this.
Go through these names and
circle how many people you know.
Now the rules of this are to
know somebody. You have to,
um, they have to know you back. So, um,
so if it's a celebrity,
um,
well here I'm one of the
names here is Johnson.
Now I've heard a magic Johnson,
but magic Johnson has never heard of me
so I cannot circle it. On the other hand,
our department chair is Marsha Johnson.
She has heard of me so I could circle it,
go through and circle it.
Circle all the people
you know who know you.
Those are the people you're connected to.
If you know more than one person
with us with the same last name,
circle it twice.
If you don't have this piece of
paper and you want to participate,
please raise your hand. And when did
teaching fellows will bring it to you.
Okay,
I'm going to talk a little bit more about
this while people go through this. Um,
the issue of connections between
people is intellectually interesting.
For many reasons and might allow us to,
um,
to develop some generalizations
about how people interact.
The game of six degrees of separation
has of course turned into a famous movie
trivia thing,
um,
revolving around to actor Kevin Bacon I
think chosen just because at Ryan's was
separation.
Um,
and the game of six degrees of Kevin
Bacon is played by taking any actor and
computing how many steps it
would take to get to Kevin Bacon.
And some computer scientists have
developed this. They've gone through, uh,
each of the quarter million actors,
actresses on the international movie
database and computed their bacon number.
And the Bacon number is the number of
steps it takes for them to get to Kevin
Bacon. Um, so for instance,
Ed Asner was in the movie a
change of JFK with Kevin Bacon.
So Ed Asner has a bacon number of one.
Elvis Presley was in the movie
change of habit with Ed Asner,
and that's as closest
connection to Kevin Bacon.
So Elvis Presley has
a bacon number of two.
It turns out that if you look at the 2.5,
sorry,
the quarter million people,
um,
on the movie database and
compute their bacon number,
the average bacon number is 2.8.
That's how many steps your average
person is away from Kevin Bacon.
You could then for any actor or actress
compute the most connected one to the
most connected one would be the one for
whom the quarter million are on average.
The most connected to,
and the answer of the most connected
actor or actress is reasonably surprising.
Does anybody want to guess?
I'll start you off of what the
wrong answer. And this, by the way,
can be found on this website.
It's not John Wayne.
John Wayne has been in many
movies, 180 movies, in fact,
over 60 years. But he isn't well
connected at all because mostly he,
he was in Westerns. So we saw the
same people over and over again.
Meryl Streep also isn't dead because
Meryl Streep has the misfortune of playing
only in good movies.
So she has no connection with people
like Adam Sandler and John Claude Vonda.
Guess any guesses?
Christopher Walken is a good one.
We could look it up.
I only know a few names are
Christopher Walken is not a finalist.
Nicholas cage is an interesting case
of Nicolas Cage. Been in good movies.
I don't want to get, I'm going to
get more controversial. I want to um,
pardon me one step up.
The most connected guy.
The list accurate,
the most connected guy.
And I think this shows that
you're right is rod Steiger.
He's the most connected actor in the
history of acting because it isn't that
he's been in more movies
than everybody else.
Michael Caine private and most
movies have any person on earth. Um,
but he's been all sorts of movies.
He was in on the waterfront in the heat
of the night and really bad movies like
car pool. Um, he's been in dramas
and crime serial thrillers,
Westerns, horror movies,
science fiction, musicals. Um,
now some people are like Rod Steiger.
So some people in their day to
day lives have many interactions.
And I think one of the things we know
from interacting with people is we can
distinguish them from other people.
How many people are finished there?
Things right now. Okay. Um,
I know one person in the department who
is one of the most connected people I
know on earth. If I wanted, if I
really had to talk to Rumsfeld,
I go to this person and say,
can you get me in touch with Rumsfeld?
If I wanted to get somebody whacked,
I'd asked this guy. Um, then I,
I know someone else in the
department and as best I know,
I'm the only person she knows.
So,
um,
how many people scores below 10
on this?
How many? Between 10 and
20? Between 20 and 30.
30 and 40.
Between 40 and 50.
50 and 60.
How many people scored above 60?
Anybody above 60.
Um, Gladwell's done this
in a lot of places. Um,
the average is 21 among a college crowd.
Some people score as high as over
a hundred. Um, the older you are,
the more the higher you tend to score,
maybe,
obviously not the longer you've been in
the country, the high you tend to score.
Um, journalists tend to
score reasonably high. Um,
academics not so high.
And,
but what Gladwell points out
that some people have the gift,
some people are more social than others.
And this connects in all sorts of
interesting ways. The issue of connection,
um,
has social factors and it's one answer
that sociologists give for why it's good
to go to Yale.
So
one answer is well, because of
the great intellectual benefits,
put that aside, let's be
more cynical here. Um,
another answer is that you
develop powerful friends,
okay.
And that's closer.
But the interesting answers sociologists
come to is it's not so much you develop
powerful friends.
Rather you developed powerful
acquaintances through Yale.
You a lot of people and they don't have
to be your close friends but they're
acquaintances and sociologists point out
that for a lot of aspects of your life,
like getting a job,
acquaintances matter,
connections matter and the connections
you established by going to a place like
Yale hold you in good stead
for the rest of your life.
Above and beyond any intellectual
qualities of this place may offer.
Um, here's what going to do
for next lecture and a half,
two lectures.
We're first going to talk about the self,
then when talk about the self and other
basically differences between how we
think of ourselves and how
we think about other people.
Then want to talk exclusively,
but how we think about other people.
And then we'll talk about how we think
about groups like Harvard students or gay
people or black people.
Um,
I'll start with my favorite
finding of all time.
And this is about the
self and this is about
the spotlight effect.
So my mornings are often
rushed because I have two kids.
So I get up and sometimes they don't
set the alarm and they get up late.
I stagger it a bed, I wake the kids,
I greet the servants, I get ready,
I make,
I make breakfast,
I run out of the house and then
usually around three o'clock,
so many points out,
in one case,
a homeless man that I have a big glob
of shaving cream in my ear or cause I
neglected to actually look in
the mirror while I shaved. Um,
or I won't spend to a party and I found
my shirt was misaligned. Seriously.
Misalign not one button. But anyway, um,
so and so I feel when this happens,
um,
I'm very mature and I basically feel
this is the end of the world. This is,
this is humiliating and everybody notices.
And so the question is how many people
notice when something happens and the
spotlight effect?
Well,
before talking about my
favorite experiment ever, um,
there was an episode of the Simpsons
that provides a beautiful illustration of
the spotlight effect and then it has a
beautiful illustration of psychological
testing. So I'll give you them
quickly, one after the other.
So Tom Gilovich,
a social psychologist,
was interested in the question
of the spotlight effect,
which is when we wear a pink shirt to
work shaving cream in her ear or whatever,
do we systematically over estimate
how much other people notice?
And he did a series of experiments and
in one experiment what he did was he got
it and subject standard
intro psych drill and said,
I want you to wear a tee shirt for the
next day and I want it to have a picture
on it.
And he got them to wear tee shirts that
had pictures on it that were the most
embarrassing pictures that they could
have on it. It turns out that I'm,
if you ask people what's the worst
picture to have on a tee shirt that you're
wearing?
The number one answer is Hitler
tied with Barry Manilow.
MMM.
The best pictures to have
on your tee shirt are, um,
Martin Luther King Jr and Jerry Seinfeld.
It turns out that people in any had
them go about their day and asked him,
how many people noticed your t shirt?
And then the psychologist went
around and they asked the people,
how many of you noticed
this person's tee shirt?
And it turned out they got it
wrong by a factor of about to,
about, they thought, say
a hundred people notice.
But 50 people noticed and across study
after study after study deal Lubitsch and
his colleagues have found
support for the spotlight effect,
which is that you believe that
people are noticing you all the time,
but they aren't. They're
busy noticing themselves. Um,
and this is actually a
useful thing to know.
Um, Gilovich got interested in this, um,
because he's interested in
the psychology of regret.
And it turns out that if you actually
asked dying people are really old people
basically, what do you
regret from your life? Um,
they regret the things as a
rule that they didn't try,
but when you asked them
why they didn't try it,
the answers tended to be I would look
silly and it turns out interesting to know
that people just don't care as
much as other people think you are.
You could take that as good
news or bad news. But um,
but the spotlight is not on
us as much as we think it is.
There's a second effect Gilovich
discovers called the transparency effect.
And the transparency effect
is quite interesting.
The transparency effect is that we believe
that we're more transparent than we
are.
I need somebody up here
who thinks that he or she is a bad liar.
Just I just need you
to say three sentences.
I'll even tell you what
it is ahead of time.
I'm going to ask you three questions.
Have you been in London?
Do you have a younger sibling?
And do you like Sushi?
I want you to answer one
of those answers there.
I want you to lie about one of them.
The task will be for everybody else to
recognize and guess which one you're
lying about. Do you want to go? Yeah. And,
and I will even write down
which one you should lie.
So I want you to lie as to that number.
Okay.
Have you ever been in London?
No,
I am not going in London.
Do you have a younger sibling?
Do you like Sushi? No, I do not. See,
okay, let's have a vote. She
was lying of a, one of them
who votes for one?
Who Votes?
Who Votes for three? Pretty much
of a tie between two and three.
You could say which one you were lying.
Three.
The fact there are two
aspects of the effect.
One aspect is um,
people are actually quite good at lying.
It is a rare person who
couldn't stand up there and the,
and everybody would figure
out what they're lying about.
But the transparency of fact
is we don't feel that way.
We often feel like things bleed out of us.
And so people will systematically over
estimate the extent to which other people
notice their secrets.
And this is actually in general why it's
sometimes difficult to teach or to door
to tell stories because we constantly
overestimate how much other people know.
Um, we think of ourselves as
more transparent than we are.
A second social psychological
phenomena is you think you're terrific.
Um,
if I ask people how well are
you doing in intro psych,
uh, this semester and I asked you to
give yourself a percentage rating,
um,
relative to the rest of the class,
then if everybody was accurate or
at least not systematically biased,
the number should add to add up to 50%.
I mean,
roughly half of you are doing better
than average and roughly half of you are
doing worse than average.
It turns out though that people will
systematically and dramatically view
themselves as better than average.
They will view themselves as better than
average when asked how good they are as
a student, as a teacher, as her lover,
and particularly as a driver,
everybody who drives thinks that
he or she is a wonderful driver.
This has been called the lake woebegone
effect based on garrison Keillor's story
about place where all the
children are above average.
And the lake woebegone
effect in psychology involves
a systematic bias to see
ourselves as better than average.
What psychologists don't really know is
why the lake woebegone effect exists.
And there are a couple of proposals.
Um,
one is the nature of the
feedback we get. So, um,
so for a lot of aspects of your life,
you only get feedback when you're good.
When you do something good in a normal,
productive, healthy, happy environment,
people don't scream at you,
but how bad you're doing,
but they compliment how good you are.
And that could lead to an inflated self
esteem on the part of people in certain
domains. Another possibility is there's
different criteria for goodness.
Um, for a driver. For instance,
when I asked you to rank how
good you are as a driver, um,
what people often do is they think
they say I'm better than an average,
but what they do is they focus
on one aspect of their driving.
So some of you might say, Hey,
I'm just a great parallel Parker.
I'm a great driver. Others might
say, I'm very careful. Great driver.
Others might say, I take chances,
no one else will. Great driver.
But above and beyond that,
there does seem to be a psychological
effect manifested here in manifested
elsewhere, which is a motivation
to feel good about yourself.
You think you're important, which
is why the spotlight effect, um,
exists.
You think your thoughts bleed out,
which is why the
transparency effect exists.
But above and beyond that in a normal,
healthy mind,
you think you're terrific.
And so this shows up in all sorts of ways.
It shows up as well in what's
been called a self serving bias.
Half of you did above
average on the midterm,
half of you did below
average on the midterm.
But if I went up and asked each of you,
um,
why the answers would not be symmetrical,
people who did well in the midterm
would describe it in terms of their
capacities or abilities.
They'd say it's cause I'm smart,
hardworking,
brilliant.
People who did poorly would
say the midterm was unfair.
I was busy, I had better
things to do with my time. Um,
professors as well.
Um,
when people get papers accepted it
is because the papers are brilliant.
When they got them rejected it's because
there's a conspiracy against them by
jealous editors and reviewers.
There's this asymmetry all the time they
cemetery has been found in athletes and
CEOs and an accident reports.
And again this is a sort of a
positive enhancement technique.
You think that you're terrific
and because you're a terrific, um,
the good things that happened to you
are due to your terrific minus the bad
things are due to accident in misfortune.
The final aspect of self that I want to
talk about is the idea that what you do
make sense,
and this is one of the more interesting
sub domains of social psychology.
The idea was developed by
the social psychologist Leon
Festinger and it's called
cognitive dissonance theory.
And would Festinger was interested in was
the idea that what happens when people
experience an inconsistency in their
heads and he claimed it causes an
unpleasant emotional state.
What he described as dissonance and
he argued that we act so as to reduce
dissonance.
When there's a contradiction in our heads,
we're not happy and we'll take steps
to make the contradiction go away.
This all sounds very general,
but there are some striking demonstrations
of this and how it could work in
everyday life. So it's
very simple example. Um,
is that is the confirmation bias.
Some of you are politically right wing.
Some of you are politically left wing.
If I asked you what magazines you read,
it turns out people who are right
wing read, right wing magazines,
people are left wing. We
left wing magazines. Um,
because people don't as a rule enjoy
getting information that disconfirms what
they believe in.
They want to have information that
confirms what they believe in and that
supports if you support Bush,
you're going to be looking for good news
about Bush. If you don't support them,
you'd be looking for bad news.
Um,
and this manifests itself in
all sorts of interesting ways.
I'll tell you about a very simple
experiment. Um, I, it was done by, um,
by Louisa Eagan here at Yale.
And it illustrates a point
which is going to end,
and I'll talk about real world
implications of this. It's very simple.
You have three m and m's.
You pretest to make sure the person
doesn't like any M and m more than the
other. There's three m
announced, who cares?
But then you ask them to choose between
two of them. So I suppose they choose,
uh, the red one. You got to choose
one. So they get to eat the red one.
Now they're offered you take the red one
away and now they're offered a choice
between the two remaining ones.
It turns out to a tremendous degree.
And you could imagine yourself in
that situation. They choose this one,
the one that wasn't the one they turn
now and the is that when you choose this,
in order to justify your decision,
you Denon great.
The one you didn't choose.
And so this one you didn't choose
is then tainted and you turn.
And then when compared to a third one,
you favor that third one.
Um,
what's particularly interesting
is you get this effect easily with
undergraduates, but you also get
with four year olds and with monkeys.
So the same denigration tends
to be more general. Well
that's a laboratory effect,
but there's some more interesting
manifestations of cognitive business.
One is the insufficient
justification effect,
which is so famous that had a cartoon
based on it. Um, the guys has,
why should I hire you as my,
as my consultant, the dog.
Some dog says I'll use my special,
the special process of cognitive
dissonance to improve employee morale.
How does it work?
Well,
when people are in an absurd situation,
their minds rationalize it by
inventing a comfortable illusion.
Not quite right when people
are having internal conflict,
when there's something uncomfortable.
That's, that's right. Um,
so it says that this person,
isn't it strange you have this dead end
job when you're twice as smart as your
boss. The hours are long,
the pay as mediocre. Nobody
respects your contribution,
yet you freely choose to work
here. It's absurd. No, wait,
there must be a reason I must work here
cause I love this work. I love this job.
This actually works. Um,
here's the classic experiment.
A Festinger gave two groups
of people are really boring.
Task paid one of them $20,
which back when this study
was done was real money,
gave another group of subjects $1,
which was insultingly small,
then asked them later,
what do you think of the task?
It turns out that the group that
had were paid a dollar rated,
the task is much more fun
than the group given $20.
So think about that for a moment.
You might have predicted it the other
way around a $20. Wow. Well, $20.
I must've enjoyed it cause I got $20.
But in fact,
the logic here is the people who have $20.
When asked,
what do you think of the task?
Could say it was boring.
I did it for $20.
The people paid $1.
We're like the character and the
Dilbert cartoon when paid a dollar.
Um, they, they said, well,
I don't want to be a donkey.
I don't want to be a sort of guy who
does this boring thing for a dollar.
It wasn't that bad, really.
It was kind of interesting.
I learned a lot to justify what they did.
This has a of real world implications.
Um,
Festinger did a wonderful study
with people, a group of people,
and he wrote this up in a book
called when prophecy fails,
who were convinced that
the world was going to end.
So they went on a mountain and
they waited for the world to end.
They had a certain time and date
when the world was going to end.
He hung out with them and then the
time passed and the world didn't end.
What people then said, and this
is what he was interested. So,
so people's predictions were totally
proven wrong and they stayed.
They left their families,
they gave away their houses,
they gave way older possessions,
they lost all their money.
But what Festinger found
was they didn't say,
God, I'm such a moron. Rather they said,
this is fantastic.
This is exactly,
this shows that us going to the mountain
has delayed the ending of the world and
this shows that we're doing
exactly the right things.
I couldn't have been smarter.
And in general,
when people devote a lot of energy
or money or expenses, something,
they are extraordinarily resistant
to having a proven wrong.
Now people have manipulated cognitive
dissonance in all sorts of ways.
And for instance, um, hazing,
hazing is cognitive dissonance at work.
Um,
fraternities and med schools
and other organizations,
haze people. What they do is when people
entered a group, they humiliate them,
they cause them pain,
they caused him various forms of
torture and unpleasantness. Why?
Well,
because it's very successful at
getting somebody to like the group.
If I join a fraternity, it
is also by the way, illegal.
So, but if I were to join
a fraternity and they say,
welcome to the fraternity, Dr
Loom here, have a mint and,
and then we have good time and
everything. I'm thinking, okay,
sounds like a fun idea.
But if I join a fraternity and they pour
cow poop on my head and make me make me
stand in the rain for a month wearing
candy hose while they throw rocks at me,
I even think it,
I think God,
I went through a lot of stuff
to get into this fraternity.
It must be really good. And
in fact, hazing through card,
inner dissonance draws the inference
that this is really, really valuable.
Um,
and this is why it exists.
If you are a political,
if you are running for office,
you will tend to have volunteers
and not necessarily pay people.
One reason, this is obvious,
it's cheaper not to pay people,
but the other reason is more interesting.
If you don't pay people,
they are more committed to the cause.
Again, it's cognitive dissonance.
If you pay me $10,000 a
month to work for you,
I'll work for you and I'll think
I'm doing it for $10,000 a month.
That makes a lot of sense.
But if I do it for nothing,
then I have asked myself, why am
I doing it? And I will conclude,
I must think very highly of you.
Um,
therapy for free tends
to be useless therapy.
This is one therapist asked for
money for all sorts of reasons,
including they like money.
But one reason why they asked for
money is if you don't pay for therapy,
you don't think it has any value.
You have to give up something.
So cognitive dissonance will lead you
then to think that what you are giving up
for has some value and then
you establish a liking for it.
Finally called her destination
shows up with children.
One of the most robust and replicated
findings in education or developmental
psychology is very simple.
You take two groups of kids and you ask
them to do something like draw pictures.
Half of the kids you reward,
maybe give them a sticker or a toy.
The other half you don't reward.
Now according to a sort of a simple
minded view of operant conditioning and
behavior psychology,
the children you reward should do it more.
That's how operating conditioning works.
In fact though,
the children who you reward later on,
I think that this activity has less value
and they're less likely to do it when
there's no reward present.
And the idea again is the kids who don't
get rewarded say to themselves, well,
I just spend time doing it.
It must have an intrinsic value.
While the children who get rewarded,
say, I did it for the sticker,
I did it for the toy.
I don't care much for this.
And so rewarding children has a danger,
which is if you give them too much reward
and too much of value for what they're
doing, um, they will then
in grade the activity.
Now we need to be careful
here about what's going on.
It's not simple inconsistency. So go
back to this insufficient justification,
a effect.
So the doner group rated a task
is more fun than a $20 group.
And it's true. Each group needed a
justification for lying about the task.
Each group need a justification for
saying how interested in task was,
but they each had a justification. They
were each doing it for money after all.
So cognitive dissonance is
a little bit more subtle.
It's not just that there's a clash.
Rather,
um,
we adjust our belief to make ourselves
look more moral and rational than we are.
Go back to hazing.
There's a perfectly good reason why I
let them do all those things. To me,
I'm the sort of person who will
let people do those things. To me.
The problem is that's not
an answer I can live with.
So cognitive dissonance motivates me to
create an answer that's more comfortable
for me.
An answer such as this must be a really
wonderful group with a wonderful bunch
of people.
Okay.
And in other words, we are biased
to believe that we are terrific.
So to sum up,
there are three main findings about you
that come out from social psychology.
One is you believe everybody
notices you even when they don't.
You're,
you're the hero of your story.
The second one is you're terrific.
You are better than average in
every possible way, each one of you.
And finally, what you do make
sense. If it doesn't make sense,
you'll destroy. It doesn't make
sense, are more to the point.
If it's something that would,
that,
that you do that's foolish or makes
you look manipulative, are cheap,
um, you will distort it in your
head so that it does make sense.
I want to move now to how we
think about self and other,
how we think about ourselves relative
to how we think about other people.
And this brings us to the
notion of attribution.
Attribution is a claim about the
cause of somebody's behavior.
Um,
and
Hyder.
Now there's all sorts of
reasons for somebody's behavior.
Suppose as you insult me or
suppose you're very kind to me,
I could say you're a kind
person or you're a rude person.
I could say this must be
a great day for you are,
you must be a lot of stress under a
lot of stress. You must want something.
There's different sorts of
attributions we could make to people.
But hiders insight is we tend to
attribute other people's actions to their
personality characteristics,
to,
to longstanding aspects of what they are.
Okay.
And this is known as a person bias and
more generally people tend to give too
much weight to the person and not
enough weight to this situation.
This is also sometimes known as
the fundamental attribution error,
which is one of the core
ideas in psychology is that
we tend to over attribute
things to a person's personality
or desires or nature.
Um,
and not enough to the
situation or the context.
There's a lot of demonstrations of this.
A lot of demonstrations have to do
with intelligence. So for example,
there's that human studies showing
that people tend to overestimate the
intelligence of professors.
Why?
Because I stand up here and I talk about
the one or more than one thing I know
about.
And so it's easy to infer
that I must know a lot,
but in fact by the time this
semester ends, I will tell you,
told you everything I know.
And if you stood up and started
talking to everything you knew,
you'd look really smart too.
The best study to show
this is a quiz show study,
which is you take two
people and you flip a coin.
And one of them is the quiz master and
the quizmaster gets to ask questions,
any question he or she wants and the
other person has to answer the questions
and if they play seriously, the quizmaster
is going to destroy the other person.
You know,
what was my dog's name?
Well I dunno what's the capital of the
city in which I was born on? I don't know.
And then you'd expect a third person
watching this to say, who cares?
It's just they're just doing this because
of the coin. A flipped. But in fact,
when the person watching this
has to assess their intelligence,
they give the quiz asker a higher
intelligence rate and another person after
all, he seemed to know a lot of answers.
The other person didn't get much. Right.
We tend to fail to discount the situation.
If you are giving a job talk and the slot,
this is for people in graduate school,
particularly if you were given a job
talk in a slide, projector breaks,
you're screwed.
Nobody is going to say to themselves,
oh well it's not such a good talk
cause the slide projector broke.
They'll say it's not such a
good talk because if the person,
somebody could give a talk and we get
throw smarties at him the whole time and
then you could,
then other people would say,
the person will kind of
upset during the whole talk.
I wonder if they seem like a nervous type.
Um,
this can be taken to extremes.
And the biggest extreme
is the case of actors. Um,
which is if there's ever a case,
anybody know who this is? The actor
had,
none of you have been alive in 1950.
This is Robert Young does.
Anyway, no, the part he plays,
he played and he played a doctor called
Marcus Welby in this famous show,
Marcus Welby MD.
And Marcus Welby was a wonderful doctor.
He was compassionate and kind. He
made house calls, he saved lives,
he council people.
And it turned out that Robert
Young was then the luge with male,
thousands of pieces of mail by people
asking for his advice on health matters.
Um,
and he then in a twist,
exploited the fundamental
attribution error.
People confusing the actor for the role.
Um,
exploited this by going on TV.
And exposing the benefits of Sanka
decaffeinated coffee where he produced the
famous line. I am not a
doctor, but I play one on TV.
We're upon people heard it and said,
well,
he must have some authority
then about medical matters.
It turns out that the confusion
between actors and their roles is,
is extremely common. Um, many people,
for instance,
view Sylvester Stallone as
either an actual hero during
the Vietnam war are sort
of a hero during the Vietnam War, given
all this Rambo's stuff. But in fact,
of course he played, um, he was in
a Swiss boarding school teaching,
teaching girls, uh, age 12
to 15 during the Vietnam war.
But it doesn't seem that way
because the role in facts,
how we think about the person.
Um,
when this movie came out 20 years ago,
they needed a character to play a gay man
according to IMD be where I get all my
information. They hit up all the big
stars, Harrison Ford, Michael Douglas,
and Richard Gere.
And they all turned it down because
they didn't want to play a game at him
because people would
think that they were gay.
Friday they got Harry Hamlin to do it.
Who was kind of a fearless sorta guy.
The biggest extreme of the fundamental
attribution error confusing the actor for
his role is Leonard Nimoy,
who because he played the emotionless
Vulcan smock on star trek was then
repeatedly viewed by people who saw him
on the street as if he was an actual
Vulcan.
Um,
he got sufficiently upset about this
to write a book called I am not Spock,
where he described all the ways
in which he was not a Vulcan, um,
his career where he attempted many times
to play roles that were different from
his Vulcan nature.
I'm stalled until finally,
many years later he gave
up and wrote another book
called I am smock,
where he finally conceded to the
fundamental attribution error.
Um,
if I gave this lecture
10 years ago,
I would say that the
fundamental attribution error
is a human universal, um,
something that we're born with a
fundamental aspect of human nature.
This is not entirely true though.
And we know through some very interesting
cross cultural research that compares
these biases,
um,
across different countries in this study
between the United States and India.
And it turns out that for whatever reason,
and it would take another course to
talk about the different explanations,
but people start off as a age eight not
committing to fundamental attribution
error,
but in western cultures where there's
an ideology perhaps that people are in
charge of their own destiny, the error
occurs and people over attribute,
um,
the role to the person.
In some eastern cultures there's
more of a view about faith and more
attributions to situation.
And this has been shown in many ways.
For instance,
if you look at newspaper reports about
murders in cultures like the United
States,
the report tends to emphasize the personal
characteristics of the person accused
of the murder.
In countries like India,
the reports tend to emphasize to a greater
degree the situation that the person
found himself in that might have
driven him to commit a murder.
So this is an important reminder that
just because we find something in our
culture and just because it
might well be pervasive, um,
doesn't mean necessarily
that it's universal.
Okay.
So to summarize so far, and we're going
to get just a little bit more, um,
for the rest of this lecture,
we've talked about two to
morals from social psychology.
One is enhancement of the self,
okay.
But the other is where you could call
over simplification of the other.
So we know ourselves that our behaviors
due to a complicated a cluster of the
situation and our personal nature's
when things go badly, in fact,
we'll blame the situation
when things go well.
The self-serving attribution bias,
we'll, we'll credit ourselves.
We don't do this for other people, for
other people where a lot less forgiving.
You do something stupid, that's
you're a stupid person. Um,
I do something stupid.
It's an off day.
And so you have this difference between
how we think about ourselves and how we
think about other people.
Let's talk a little bit about what we
think about other people and start by
talking about why we like other people.
And hearing when are to some extent go
over material that was raised earlier in
the course, um, in Peter
Salovey's wonderful lecture.
So some of this are liking of
other people. It is obvious
and we talked about it.
It needs Salloway's lecture.
We talked it when we talked
about sexual attractiveness. Um,
we like people who are honest, who are
kind, who are smart, who are funny.
Um,
but study after study finds more
fundamental processes are also at work.
And here's a list of three of
them. One is proximity. Um,
we tend to like people who
were close to physically,
who we are physically and spatially
close to who we spend a lot of time with.
Um,
in one study they looked at a
housing project in Manhattan
and they asked people,
um,
where their best friend was.
And 90% of them said,
my best friends in the same building as
me and 50% of them says the same floor.
Um, ask yourself, who's
your best friend at Yale?
For how many of you is it somebody
in your same college? Okay,
how many different college?
So call it a tie,
but then there's a lot more
colleges that aren't yours than one.
How many of you would you
say your best friend is?
Somebody you're currently
on your same floor? Yeah.
If you were gonna marry
somebody from this class,
it is the person you were sitting next to
now,
now
in some sense this, this, this is an
incredibly, a rather trivial finding.
Of course you're going to
get more involved in people
you encounter frequently.
Um, you know, how else is it kind of
work. But it's actually more than that.
The more you see something,
the more you like it.
And this is sometimes known
as the mere exposure effect.
The mirror exposure effect is
simply seeing something, um,
makes it likable perhaps because
it becomes comfortable and safe.
In one study by James Cutting,
cutting Todd and introduction
to psychology course,
and before each lecture he'd
flashed pictures on the screen.
You'd have a screensaver showing pictures
on the screen paintings and wouldn't
say anything about him.
He will sit down,
look at them while they prepared her
notes at the end of the semester.
He then asked people to rate different
pictures as to how much they liked them.
And even though people had no memory,
I've seen one or versus the other.
Um,
they tend to like the pictures
more than they had seen before.
They were somehow familiar
and somehow more likable.
If I showed you a picture of yourself,
um,
versus a mirror image of yourself
and ask which one you'd like more,
the answer is very strong.
You'd like your mirror image more.
Cause the image is what you
tend to see from day to day.
If I showed you your best friend,
a picture of you versus a
mirror image picture of you,
your best friend would say he or she
likes to picture more because that
corresponds to what he
or she sees each day.
Familiarity is itself a desire
for liking a force for liking
similarity. Um, we like
people who are similar to us.
Um, friends tend to be highly
similar to one another.
So to husbands and wives.
Now to some extent,
similarity is hard to
pull apart from proximity.
So the fact that you're similar to your
friends at Yale might just be because
you're close to your friends at Yale
and people who are at Yale tend to be
fairly similar to one another.
But there's a lot of evidence
that similarity above and
beyond proximity has an
effect on attractiveness and unliking.
Um,
similarity predicts the success of a
marriage and through a phenomena people
aren't exactly sure about couples become
more and more similar over the course
of a relationship.
Finally,
people like good looking people,
people like attractive people,
um,
physically attractive,
people are thought to be smarter,
more competent, more social and nicer.
Now some of you who are very cynical and
or very good looking might wonder yes,
but good looking.
People like me actually are smarter,
more competent,
more social and morally better.
This is not a crazy response. Um, it,
it could be for instance,
that the advantages of being good looking,
make your life run a lot easier.
Teachers are more responsive to you.
People treat you better,
you have more opportunities to
make your way through the world.
You make more money, you have more
access to things. And that can turn, um,
caused you to improve your life.
This would be what's known in the
Bible as a Matthew effect. Uh,
Matthew effect is a
developmental psychology phrase
for the sort of thing where,
well, as Jesus said, for
an to everyone that has,
shall be given and he shall
have abundance. That means
if you're good looking,
you'll also be smart. But from him
that hath not shall be taken away.
Even that which he hath, um, it's, it's,
it's a long version of the rich get richer
and the poor even lose what they have.
Um,
so there's a variety of studies
suggesting that teachers rate attractive
children as smarter and higher
achieving. Um, adults. Um,
think that when an ugly kid misbehaves,
it's because they have an ugly soul.
While an attractive kid.
Oh,
that little scamp somebody
must've been bothering them
when I was in University of
Arizona and we live next and all,
I remember my neighborhoods,
we lived next to this little
boy and his name was Adonis.
Cute Kid. Come on. Um,
also in mock trials,
judges give longer prisons
and it's just ugly people.
That's the Matthew effect.
It,
those who have little get even that
taken away and thrown into prison.
There was a reason study,
which I'll tell you about,
but I am not comfortable
with it as an experiment.
The study observed people in, in
a, in a shopping and in, in the,
in the parking lot of um,
of a supermarket and found that parents
were a lot refer to the kids if their
kids are ugly,
then if the kids are good looking and
they attributed it to the fact that for
all sorts of reasons, to ugly kid
just matters less to the parent. Um,
I was watching a poker game once
on TV and somebody who lost said,
and I quote,
they beat me like an ugly stepchild.
And the fate of the ugly stepchild
is in fact not a very good fate.
But this is not a good
study for one thing,
and I don't know how to phrase
this in a politically correct way,
but the parents have ugly kids are
likely to themselves be ugly people.
And maybe what they're
finding is just ugly.
People are more violent
than good looking people.
This is an excellent
time to stop the lecture.
So I'm going to stop the lecture and
we're going to continue social psychology
on Wednesday.